[Music]
welcome everyone please feel free to
come a little farther up my name is
Julie Adams I'm the head of Grace Hopper
college and a professor of sociology
here at Yale I am absolutely thrilled to
see so many students faculty staff
members of the Yale leadership and
Friends of the college here today I also
want to thank a number of special guests
for joining us on this occasion Admiral
John Richardson Rear Admiral Samuel Cox
Roger and Deborah Murray captain paul
weitz Carver captain Wayne Graz dock
commander Keith Lancer and Yale zone
ROTC welcome I would now like to
introduce the Navy bands northeast brass
quintet and musician third class Jeanne
register on keyboard will those who are
able or and who are not already standing
please stand for the national anthem
you
[Applause]
thank you for that splendid rendition of
the star-spangled banner this occasion
means a great deal to our community we
admire the astonishing achievements and
spirit of grace Murray hopper and take
inspiration from her extraordinary
accomplished life this ceremony is also
a symbolic culmination of years of
discussion in the college and at Yale
some of it recently in this very room
the Roosevelt L Thomson dining hall how
delightful that the confluence of talked
arguments and decisions produced this
excellent outcome and new beginning what
do names matter people often ask us and
we have certainly asked ourselves in
fact in that relationship among names
symbols and the multi-faceted
biographies of the people behind the
symbols they matter a great deal we do
honor to those whose names are
associated with a beautiful beloved
building and community and we hold
ourselves to high standards in so doing
we grapple intellectually with both the
complexity of the lives and experiences
that produce the people whom we honor
and their impact upon the world yes in
Yale's residential colleges we also have
and make fun with in-house nicknames
chance in intramural sports and so forth
but that doesn't diminish the respect
and affection one wit my husband
associate head of college hans van dyke
our residential college dean April
release myself we have all noticed a new
and vibrant feeling emerging in the
college as this summer turns to fall we
feel buoyed up renewed and we are
grateful on that note I am delighted to
introduce president Peter salivate who
will be making the first set of remarks
today
[Applause]
Thank You professor Adams welcome
everyone thank you all for being here
today being here to dedicate Grace
Hopper College I want to thank our
distinguished guests were with us today
as you heard were pleased that members
of the family of Rear Admiral hopper her
nephew Roger Mari his daughter Deborah
could be here today with us I want to
extend our appreciation to Admiral John
Richardson the Chief of Naval Operations
for the United States Navy for joining
us today as well
Thank You Roger Deborah Admiral
Richardson for helping us mark a
historic occasion and it's a great honor
to have you all with us today this
afternoon we honor the life of grace
Murray hopper an extraordinary Yale
graduate whose achievements spanned
decades changed the way we understand
and use computers and we also reflect on
what her life means for us today we know
that our namesakes do not like old and
still in the vast recesses of history
their lives their legacies reach across
the years and speak to us sometimes with
great force what does Grace Hopper say
to us and to Yale today first she tells
us that the examined life is the only
life worth living propelled by an
insatiable curiosity Grace Hopper was
always asking questions about the world
around her after Yale where she received
her master's and PhD in mathematics she
taught the subject at Vassar after the
bombing of Pearl Harbor and the US entry
into World War two she wanted to serve
her country
she enlisted in the Navy and was
assigned to work on the world's first
computer the mark 1 from that time
forward Grace Hopper was constantly
imagining new problems for the computer
to solve new ways to use the enormous
capabilities she envisioned for it many
people told her that computers could
never do what she wanted them to do
turns out they were wrong over the next
several decades she pioneered automatic
programming and new word based computer
languages she made it possible for
ordinary people to use computers not
just mathematicians and engineers and
she did all of this because she never
stopped thinking her curiosity was truly
endless second Grace Hopper teaches us
to embrace change humans she loved to
say are allergic to change but she
wasn't she encouraged her younger
colleagues to take risks as well she
told them it was always easier to ask
forgiveness than it is to get permission
by empowering them to think for
themselves she helped launch them on
their own successful careers
Andrew Hopper was at the vanguard of a
new era at a time when opportunities for
women especially in math and engineering
were extremely limited
she charted a remarkable course she
insisted on her place at the table in
the laboratory and at the helm as we
celebrate the history of women at Yale
soon fifty years at Yale College and a
hundred and fifty years at the
University we recognized Grace hoppers
trailblazing leadership and example
finally grace hoppers life speaks
clearly to us about the importance of
service
as a teacher mentor and distinguished
naval officer she served others and her
country with courage and dedication
Admiral Hopper received dozens of honors
and awards in her lifetime but she said
the highest award she would ever receive
was the privilege and responsibility of
serving proudly in the United States
Navy today a neural hopper calls each of
us to discover a greater purpose a
calling worthy of our curiosity talents
and creativity I've always been more
interested in the future than in the
past
she once said today we also look to the
future to the future of hopper College
here students will live learn and
challenge each other to live lives of
meaning and purpose one day like Grace
Hopper they too will change the world
thank you all for being here
[Applause]
Thank You president salivate for your
inspiring words we will now hear from
Roger Marie grace hoppers nephew it's
such a privilege to have family members
here with us today
thank you I would like to thank yelling
all those who mentioned my answer as a
candidate for a residential college name
for this and for this wonderful honor
although she left the academic world my
aunt was always a teacher at heart it is
significant that yeah I was honoring a
woman who was a pioneer in the computer
field when even today there is still
some who doubt women's abilities in this
area the PhD in mathematics
my aunt received from Yale helped pave
the way for assignment as a naval
officer to work with her Howard Aiken at
the Harvard computation lab which was
the beginning of my aunt's career with
computers my aunt was very dedicated to
her work and a very determined
individual once she had a goal she had
the ability to recognize and
successfully pursue the steps necessary
to reach that goal as I was growing up
my aunt travelled extensively for
Remington Rand she would send me from
post postcards from the places she
visited always signed hastily Grace when
my children were young she sent them
wonderful children's books which my
grandchildren are now enjoying one of
the things I enjoyed most about my aunt
was her dry sense of humor comments
usually delivered with an absolutely
straight face one time she opened a
speech by saying as I look around the
room I don't see many women but don't
worry I will go slowly and hopefully you
can keep up
if my aunt were here today I know three
things she would say to you as a naval
officer she would tell you that a ship
in port is safe but that's not what
ships are for secondly she would say the
most damaging phrase in the language is
we've always done it this way that is
why she had a clock that ran
counterclockwise in her office and
lastly and redundantly she would tell
you if it's a good idea go ahead and do
it it is much easier to apologize than
it is to get permission thank you
Thank You mr. Murray for your
reminiscences which bring Grace Hopper
vividly before us it is my honor now to
introduce the speaker for our final set
of remarks Admiral John Richardson Chief
of Naval Operations
[Applause]
well thank you very much for allowing me
to speak today president salivate thanks
for the invitation also want to just
echo my welcome to the family members of
Grace Hopper was just so wonderful that
you could be here then a shout-out to
the N ROTC unit who's here in force and
looking good in whites and I want to
thank everybody for joining us here
today as really an expression perhaps of
what has been a long and very rich
tradition of a rich relationship between
the Navy and Yale starting really back
in the Revolutionary War times when Yale
students David Bushnell invented the
submarine turtle and did an attack in
New York Harbor against a British
warship and through history there has
been just a groundbreaking relationship
almost a love story really between Yale
and the Navy in just before World War
one
it was Yale University that stood up a
flying club the millionaire's unit they
call themselves and they led the way
into a Naval Aviation in World War one
and ever since then Yale has had a close
relationship not only with the Navy but
particularly with naval aviation in 1926
this is when the Navy first officially
started the Naval Reserve Officer
Training candidate program we started
with six schools in 1926 Yale being
among those original six schools for
that scholarship program and then
through World War two
a vast relationship where you know
really opened its doors to the Navy and
other services to help train officers
and scientists and solve some of our
hardest problems during the World War
two and so it's truly an honor to be
here at Yale to celebrate that going
forward and it's what a terrific choice
to name this College after Admiral Grace
Hopper
risk-taker as you have heard a visionary
leader in the field of computer science
and again just an absolute terrific
choice to a name this college and you
know at the start of world war two as
you heard Alma Hopper gave up her career
really as in a very accomplished
university mathematics professor to join
the Navy under the women accepted for
volunteer emergency service or the waves
program perhaps the greatest acronym
ever you know as and you know you may
not know this but her initial
application into the Navy was designed
to denied because she was fifteen pounds
under the minimum weight requirement and
she was older than typical applicants at
the time and she also was working in a
field you know critical and determined
to be absolutely essential in this
civilian work force but I'll tell you
what you know there's a destroyer
that's home ported in Pearl Harbor named
the USS Grace Hopper and the call sign
for that destroyer is Amazing Grace and
you know that that weight limit was not
going to stop Amazing Grace and sure
enough she submitted a waiver was
accepted graduated first in her Officer
Candidate School class at the age of 37
and then became a naval officer and as
you've heard during her 43 year naval
career at WA hoppers pioneered work in
the field of computer programming from
her work on the very first computer the
mark one to her conceptualization and
realization of the first compiler she
really paved the way for the Navy in the
digital revolution and in many ways
we're still trying to catch up with
Admiral hoppers vision today I talk a
lot about the digital Navy and it is not
a stretch at all to consider that this
talk and our way forward as being really
influenced heavily by animal hopper in
the Midway that the Navy strives to
employ information technology and see
how these tools will be absolutely
critical in our future Navy you know in
the 1970s
amongst her other accomplishments Alma
hopper advocated for the Department of
Defense to replace these large
centralized computer systems with a
network of small distributed systems
where each user on the network could
access information in a central database
you know in many ways which is second
nature to us now we call it the cloud
she envisioned this decades ago and this
way of thinking is really the driving
force behind our current efforts to
network our fleet together in ways that
are reliable secure and that provide
maximum flexibility and so you know
these initiatives this thinking really
are only possible because of the solid
foundation that Alma hopper worked so
hard to establish and they ensure that
the US Navy will sustain operational and
technical agility in the information age
as I said in many ways we're still
trying to catch up to Admiral Hopper and
to do so we'll need to channel not only
her exquisite intellect but also her
boundless energy her bold determination
and her appetite for risk so again let
me just congratulate Yale University
again and the entire Yale student body
for this historic occasion Grace Hopper
example will serve as an inspiration for
generations of future Yale students and
faculties who will walk the halls of
this terrific place and will serve as a
sign a continuing sign of the close bond
between Yale and the Navy thank you
again for allowing me to speak
[Applause]
thank you so much Admiral your words
mean a great deal to us all we've now
arrived at the blessing portion of our
program and so I'd like to invite Sharon
Kugler University chaplain to come to
the podium they called her amazing grace
and now we call this place her namesake
our home this has been a rebirth of
sorts and we have all been caring
midwives to this beautiful and joyous
occasion Grace Hopper had a tenacious
belief in the virtue of service and the
vast capacity of innovation and though
small in physical frame she had a wide
vigorous embrace for the bright promise
of the future we can be reasonably
confident that she would be beaming with
pride and joy to see all of you gathered
here I confess that as someone who
majored in math in college and who was a
fan of her work way back then I could
not be more delighted to offer the
blessing I now invite you to join me in
a spirit of prayer Oh divine mystery you
hold us throughout all our stories and
we are elated to be together in this
space to begin a new one
bless the many students faculty and
fellows who have been an integral part
of this College in the past may they
return often smile at what they see and
take pleasure in their own cherished
memories of time spent within these
walls bless those that belong to this
College now grace Murray hopper is your
home and your considerable gifts will
thread their way through its entryways
sweets rooms tables in courtyard
creating meaningful
traditions and building a legacy that
will inspire generations to come bless
those whose labor makes this place feel
like home bless those who cook who clean
who care for the grounds and you attend
to all the countless details that make
this college flow bless those who lead
this College as they cultivate an
environment that nurtures our hearts
celebrates our discoveries guides our
way and offers safe harbor in
challenging times may all of us who are
part of this rebirth this new story be
inspired by the life of grace Murray
hopper may we to be blessed with a
tenacious belief in the great promise of
the future and may our hearts be stirred
again and again by the story of one
amazing grace for this we say with great
joy amen
I now invite professor Adams Dean Chun
and president Sall of a forward for a
special presentation
we have a special presentation to make
and the Yale Board of Trustees the Yale
corporation is represented here by John
Rice and I'm going to ask him to join us
too if he wouldn't mind this is the
official moment yes and we are going to
call on Yale College Dean Marvin Chen to
give us a little hand with this so an
important symbol of college identity is
the ceremonial mace which is usually
kept hidden until that they have
commencement for seniors this particular
new mace was created by mark theory from
Bucks County in Pennsylvania he has
created other maces for this College and
what's very meaningful about this
beautiful mace is that the wood is from
a tree that that used to stand in the in
the courtyard of this College and and
the coat of arms is here embedded at the
head and and so the Dean of Harper
College will be carrying this at
commencement every year but we brought
it out today to commemorate this
beautiful and meaningful occasion -
dedication of grace Harper College and
so we will present this to head Adams
[Applause]
thank you so much and thank you to all
of you for sharing in this special
ceremony now I'm going to turn things
over to launch our celebration to the
Navy Band Anchors Aweigh
[Music]
[Applause]
why please join us for the reception in
the courtyard and thank you again for
coming
[Music]